[Music]
you go out you make this the first
hangover you couldn't have known i'm
sure it looked like okay this could be a
good movie and then it turns into this
absolute phenomenon and this iconic
comedy movie
what's it like for you if you would say
you want to go to vegas and just hang
out how do people react to you walking
around las vegas uh well i mean it you
know it is strange that the movie has
kind of become synonymous with vague
well vegas has become synonymous with
the movie in a weird way but it's not
that different because you know people
love to drink in vegas so
you know now it's just they get drunk
and scream at me instead of getting they
get drunk and scream by character
instead of just getting drunk and
screaming at me what do they yell at you
i found doug
and everyone thinks they're the first
one to say everyone thinks and there's
no one for him he hasn't heard and
there's no answer to it right because
they and a lot of them come up to you
and they won't scream at somebody they
should be like hey i found doug yeah and
i speak what do i say to that yes you
found the guy but uh no people love to
drink i mean it's a bizarre place to go
like i we were we all went to dinner
because we were just there doing press
and everything and you you know you have
to walk through uh a mall usually like
forum shops and stuff and people are
just like there's teenage girls sitting
outside of banana republic with like
those hurricane drinks just wasted yeah
it's bizarre that you see people getting
drunk in a mall it's the only place that
you see that again it's what i find uh
the very essence of america yes
again we fought wars for that i don't
know what you're complaining about i
also i got a chance to go to see the
rolling stones which was like a chance
in the lifetime and uh the people in
front of me were wasted and they were
making out in the first song and then by
the third song the woman had passed out
and the guy
her her beau
gathered
her hair
in in the ponytail and just helped
because she was literally passed out
like that and he gathered her hair and
held her head up while still watching
the concert
that's nice
he could have just tied it to something
and i'm good
you know there's a
talk about the hangover being such an
iconic part of uh las vegas there's a
hangover slot machine yeah we actually
uh yeah we have a picture of it there's
um there's a slot machine that it's all
that's hangover themed have you played
the slot machine have you i haven't i
haven't played it but i know last time i
was there i think ed helms said he he
played it and uh i think he said it was
actually too complicated for him to
figure out how to play and he's a pretty
smart guy yeah he was like i tried the
slot machine i was like
i don't know you got to ask him when he
comes it's bizarre how could you be well
because there are some that like you can
pull in multi coins and then you can win
you know that so you just i don't
they're too complicated too i just put
in money and hit a button and see what
happens
the way you acted it out was like i put
my money in and then i just want it to
be over
you just you're like a machine putting
money into a machine yeah great